-Thank you all for being here.
I know you guys pretty well.
Nicole, we're new friends.
For those of you
who don't know Nicole,
she is an amazing
writer-director.
"Enough Said."
"Friends with Money."
I'm so happy that you're here.
Thank you.
-Thank you so much.
-I'm not saying that you have
friends with money. Sorry.
They're the titles of the film.
-Well, I do have friends
with money.
-Yeah, you do.
-Clearly.
-How did you get involved with
these guys for this project?
-I got an e-mail
from Ben saying --
Who I knew a little bit.
We were mutual fans
of one another --
-I was jealous of her,
basically, is the truth.
-Is that right?
-Yeah, well, we met because
we had movies come out
the same weekend.
I think one was "Daredevil,"
and they said it was, like,
the worst film ever made,
and I turn the page,
and it was like,
"Nicole Holofcener
is a modern-day Jane Austen."
I'm like, "How do I get this?"
-You go, "Yeah, boy,
these are different reviews."
-I've been trying
to work with her ever since.
-Yeah. It was very flattering.
And, so, he e-mailed me,
and I think you might have said,
you know, a medieval movie.
I'm not sure.
But whatever it was,
I thought it was a joke.
-Because you don't write
medieval movies.
-Oh, I'm the go-to
swordfight movie woman.
-That is not your type
of writing at all.
-No, it's not.
-No.
-But I was thrilled
and flattered,
and I met with them,
and, you know, I said,
"I don't know how
to write like this."
This milady, milordy.
My lady, my lordy. See?
-"Milordy."
He said that's not really --
-You were making
that word up, yeah.
-Luckily, we were like,
"Neither do we." So...
-Well, you heard of this book
first. Is that right?
-Yeah, yeah. I had the book.
Someone at our company
gave it to me,
and I read it and sent it
to Ridley Scott and --
-It's got to be Ridley Scott.
-Yeah.
It just really felt like
right in his wheelhouse and --
-It's a big movie.
-It's a very, very big, medieval
kind of something.
You know, this whole world
that he could really create.
And then I showed it to Ben,
and we decided to write it,
and the way we thought of doing
it was in these three different
perspectives --
two male perspectives
and one female perspective.
Because it's about
these two knights.
This is a true story.
It's the last sanctioned duel
in medieval France
between these two knights,
one of whom claimed
the other raped his wife,
and they fought to his death.
And so we saw it
as this story of perspective,
and so we needed somebody
to write the female perspective,
and she's our favorite writer,
so we were like,
"Well, why don't we just beg?"
-"Let's get Jane Austen."
[ Laughter ]
-Get the best. Why not?
-She was dead, so we...
-Jane Austen wasn't available.
-Yeah.
-So you guys
wrote the female part.
-And you did
the male part, yeah.
-Exactly.
-Did you find it challenging?
Because obviously,
and unfortunately,
a lot of male perspective
has been written about,
and women's perspective
actually --
No one's really --
-Who?
-Yeah. Yeah, who are women.
-Yeah, what?
-How sad is that?
But, I mean,
is it exciting kind of?
-Yeah.
-Because it's a challenge
to find out actually what is
her perspective, her story.
-Yeah, there wasn't that much
written in the book about her.
There are a few things
we know about her.
She spoke many languages.
She was really smart.
And clearly she was
an incredibly brave woman
to speak out
the way she did then.
And so I just had to
make some stuff up
with a lot of research
and help to figure out,
like, what exciting things
did women do in 1360?
It's like, well,
they crocheted.
-Yeah.
-They got to play music.
-Yeah. Wow.
-They were property
of their husbands...
-Geez.
-...and had no rights or agency,
so they had a blast.
-Yeah, yeah.
Not gonna be a reality show.
-No.
-No. Okay, yeah, understood.
You guys wrote
"Good Will Hunting" --
it was 25 years ago,
I want to say.
You haven't written a movie
since. Why?
-I mean, I think that "Good Will
Hunting" took us so long.
we were, like, unemployed,
broke guys.
Like, it took us forever
to write that screenplay.
I think we wrote thousands
and thousands of pages.
We didn't really know
what we were doing,
and I think that kind of
put us off writing again,
because we never thought
we'd have the time.
And I think
we found writing this
that we actually kind of
picked up structure
over the last 25 years
of kind of making movies,
and so it went a lot faster.
And then we also made
the really good decision
of getting a great writer
to come with us, so...
-Yeah.
-I was like, "Come on, boys."
-"Come on, boys." Yeah.
-I have a photo here of -- -
It's like, "You see
what I had to deal with?"
-This is the "Good Will Hunting"
movie premiere.
It's at the Ziegfeld.
December 1997.
-You wouldn't imagine
that those two idiots
would still be around.
-What do you remember
about this?
This is -- Do you remember this?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I guess.
I'm not sure what was
going through my head there.
Looks a little like
a "Zoolander" outtake.
It was kind of like very --
You know, I mean,
I think that, like,
we were just shocked
that it all happened
and wouldn't have imagined
getting another job.
The whole thing
of "Good Will Hunting"
was really just to make them
a video cassette
that was like an acting reel.
You know what I mean?
Because we were like,
"Well, we can't get the job.
Just show that we can do
interesting stuff."
So the whole thing was have a
reel and show casting directors.
And so we'll write
these parts for ourselves,
and it was at a time when there
were, like, these filmmakers
that start, like -- Spike Lee
did "Do the Right Thing,"
and Richard Linklater
did "Slacker,"
and Kevin Smith did "Clerks."
-There was this whole sort of --
And Quentin did
"Reservoir Dogs."
It was like, "No, you don't
have to do the studios.
You can do it cheap,
and you get a movie star,
and I'll make it
for a million bucks,"
and so we wrote, like, a movie
that's just all, you know,
interiors and people talking in
rooms 'cause it was inexpensive.
And they were like,
"Write the cool monologues,
and we'll get a famous guy
and, you know..."
It was sort of put together
as -- That was our ambition.
So I think we were shocked
that it even got released.
-I mean, you know, we've heard
about you and heard stories.
Oh, you guys are old friends
and you've known each other
a long time.
But you actually do know
each other a long time
and are old friends.
This is a photo.
I think you sent it to Matt
just the other day just to go,
"Hey, remember these dudes?"
Here's 17-year-old Matt and Ben
in a photo booth.
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, listen.
Hard not to see that those guys
are going to make it.
-Yeah, those guys clearly have
"star" written all over them.
-That's awesome.
-You know, I think it's the
matching puka necklaces
that give it away.
-Best buddies.
That's BFFs right there.
Come on.
That's BFFs for life.
-Nicole, you should write
a movie with those guys.
-No way.
-No way. You would never do it.
More with Nicole Holofcener,
Matt Damon,
and Ben Affleck
after the break, everyone.
We're going to talk about
"The Last Duel."